all right michelle
michelle where did you grow up where are
you from originally oh originally um i
grew up in a town called spice land in
indiana
but i was born out in newcastle indiana
like right in between a cornfield and
some cattle
um it's like if
driving on the road if you blink
you miss the whole town
[Music]
so very very rural very redneck very
redneck very right southern indiana uh
east central
yeah
and uh
you had mom and dad growing up
yes and now um
i had my uh my mom and my
real dad um until i was almost eight and
then i was uh
you know fostered and then adopted by my
adopted father why did your parents lose
you
well um
my real dad was
the most horrible person in the world um
my sister and i
we were basically like the family income
at four years old my real dad started
molesting me
and then by before i was seven i was
like five or six he started raping me
and he let his friends
rape me and my sister
like
video it like
it's uh
yeah it kind of sucked um did mom step i
mean your mom's mom didn't care um i
don't think she believed me uh she said
she didn't she said that i was lying
my sister never said anything
and i told a teacher when i was in
second grade
and the teacher believed me and she
called cps
so and that's how your parents lost you
kind well at first they did cps when
they showed up they never talked to me
they never talked to my sister
um they talked to my mom and my dad and
they
they basically decided that like i was
trying to get attention
and
i was punished for that
because after the caseworker left you
know obviously they were pissed
and
i don't really remember
you know
after like the first couple beatings
like he beat the [ __ ] out of me
um but i woke up
in the hospital and
um like that's the next thing i remember
i don't know if i blocked it out or
you know um but after that i went to
foster care
so you and your sister both
yeah but they separated us
yeah and how was your childhood after
that
well
i went through several foster homes um i
was scared of the foster dads the foster
brothers and stuff anything with a penis
i was scared of it
and
i had to go through like
i don't know like therapy i guess
call it at the cps office
and uh three to five times a week just
depending
and
one day a single man a marine
came in to turn in some paperwork or
something and he saw me and he came and
started talking to me
and i like it wasn't scared of him
he was like the coolest guy in the world
he just
he asked me what i was doing i was
playing with my dolls
and he came up and he asked me what my
doll's names were
and
i was comfortable around him
and then i don't know
like how he ended up
you know getting me i guess he asked my
my caseworker whatever what my story was
and
they took a chance on him a single a
single man you know
and
within a year after that he adopted me
so my life was great from 8 until almost
13.
and then a month and a day before my
13th birthday on november 2nd 1994
at 1102 pm
my adopted dad
shot himself in the head
and i was the only person in the house
so
after that it kind of got rocky again
that's a heavy childhood
it's
it is what it is i mean
it uh
it kind of made me numb
like
nothing
nothing really got to me after that
so
that was 13
a month and a day before
and where did you where did your
remaining teen years ago
my mom got me back
um my real dad
to avoid going to jail well he went to
jail um
and
my
paternal grandmother
put the house up put her house up for
his bail and he took off f2
i believe it was clearwater florida i
think
somewhere in florida and so he couldn't
get extradited because i guess well
obviously he didn't want to go to prison
so i mean especially for something like
that
but um so he avoided prison time
yeah he did like maybe 48 hours in the
county jail before he was able to get
bailed out
and that's like all he ever all he ever
got until the day he died there was
still warrants out for him though
but
my mom got me back
it was it was okay at first it was cool
she was like
she like
was a shitty mom but she was a good
friend
um like i remember i was 14 years old
and on my 14th birthday she was doing
lines of coke with me
and you know at the time that was the
coolest thing in the world
but uh looking back like she should have
had her ass kicked for that
you know that that wasn't
that wasn't even okay but my sister
um she's uh seven years older than me
um
like she got pregnant on purpose
to get out of you know like foster care
and stuff so um
she was 15 when she got pregnant and
then on her 16th birthday she was
emancipated and she got married to her
her first baby's daddy
so
um
like
my mom
my mom
jumped around a lot in relationships
and the guys she went for were like my
age pretty much um
her uh
the greatest quote i think i ever heard
from that woman's mouth was if you get
one young enough you can raise him the
way you want him
and i always thought it was kind of
funny
but it was nothing to come home from
school and
catch one of my friends in the kitchen
leaning up against the counter and my
mom on her knees sucking them off
so
like i didn't spend a lot of time at
home when she was doing that
and then like
you know when i would be at home half
the time if she had a boyfriend or she
got married again or something half the
time the guy was trying to touch me too
so
you know but i was already kind of used
to it
[Music]
what kind of kid were you in high school
like for a while at first i was like
really quiet um
shy a small town so everybody knew what
happened to me when i was little
and unfortunately
i don't know how it is out here but in
indiana
when um the kid goes into like foster
care
they keep the kid in the same school um
and they try to keep the kid in like the
same town or like the same general area
so um it doesn't like shock them to
where they have to you know make all new
friends and you know all that
um
in my case i think it would have been
preferable
because like
the kids at school might not have known
exactly you know what the case was with
me and my sister
but their parents did
and
kids are cruel but adults are worse
and like the kids weren't allowed to
play with me because of what my real dad
had done to me
even though
he wasn't around
you know they didn't want their kids to
be friends with me so
you know i was standoffish i was quiet i
didn't have friends
and then i was like
15
16
i kind of went wild
like all my friends were guys
and
all my friends do drugs
um
so
went in rome
you know um then when i was 16 i was in
a car accident on my sweet 16th birthday
of all the days in the [ __ ] world all
the days
uh my mom let me skip school
and we were going into indianapolis she
was going to take me shopping in broad
ripple
now broad ripple's like
the artsy fashion district in
indianapolis
um
it was like the late mid 90s
so it was still like the
the whole style was like the retro you
know throwback to the 60s
and uh
like in broad ripple they had all these
vintage stores
that had like all the clothes you know
that
they wore in like the summer of love in
san francisco and [ __ ] like that and
there was like these you know old record
stores you know this old real vinyl and
i collected vinyl
a huge collection of vinyl
and uh
she was gonna take me shopping
and uh we were just gotten into the city
and we were the first car stopped at a
stoplight
and a truck carrying christmas trees
rear-ended us
doing what they said was over 70 miles
an hour and the guy never hit the break
and i remember reaching for my soda yeah
they said it was sitting in the cup
holder and i remember reaching for my
soda after feeling the impact so it
wouldn't spill
don't know why i know it's like the
stupidest thing
but
i woke up a few hours after that
and the pain
from opening my eyes was so intense it
made me throw up
and
i came home from the hospital with a
prescription of oxycontin
and
um
which i was on for a very very long time
oxycontin
morphine
percocets for breakthrough pain
two fentanyl patches one on each
72 hours
a couple times a week i go to the
hospital to get a shot of dilaudid
this is all doctor prescribed
as
they said i had the adult equivalent to
shaken baby syndrome
so um
there was like a lot of brain damage
and like everyone was was really
surprised doctors and
you know family friends everybody i was
really surprised that i was able to
actually
you know get somewhat better and like
not be
you know
some kind of
like
[ __ ]
you know vegetable
[Music]
um
that started uh
that's what started my my opiate
addiction before that i i
i did you know coke with my mom
i smoked weed but
i i thought of anybody that did pills
you know pain pills or like heroin or
anything you know other junkies or
pieces of [ __ ]
but by the time i was 17 i was doing
heroin because the oxies didn't do
anything anymore
so
at 18
i quit school
i got my ged and started working
what kind of
work have you done since
uh
got a little bit of everything um
waited tables
um
i was actually pretty good with waiting
tables
like
i was kind of like a people person
um
i worked at the walmart
you know
it was a redneck town so i had to have a
redneck job
i did a lot of factory work foundry work
through temp agencies
other than that it was a mom
stay-at-home mom
you got married yeah
um my first husband
[Music]
well i got pregnant and we got married
because i got pregnant
i had a little boy
and when he was
about 15 months old my first husband
passed away
i was
like less than a month pregnant with my
oldest daughter and didn't know it yet
oh um he actually he overdosed
in bed next to me and i didn't know it
and
i i got up and you know was making
breakfast and feeding my son the alarm
clock kept going off
and i didn't know why so when i went in
and checked on him
like his eyes were open he was cold
so
um
that was
that that really [ __ ] me up um
i gave him the xanax that that sent him
over the edge
um i did um
i i didn't know
see we were we were on methadone
and we were trying to get clean for you
know for our son
and uh
he had relapsed and i didn't know he had
relapsed
and i gave him one bar xanax
because he was having trouble sleeping
he worked seconds
and uh
he was having trouble sleeping
so i gave him a bar and
like i've done it a hundred times before
thank you
thank you
um
and i found out that
a couple weeks after his funeral
i found out that i was pregnant with our
daughter
who will be 14 or who just turned 14. oh
lord
ah what am i thinking
my oldest will be 16 in a few days
that's crazy where are your kids now
indiana they're uh they're in foster
care
i have five kids total
um by two different men
um
my oldest sue
just said their dad passed away and my
youngest three
their dad is
the piece of [ __ ]
that
cost me all five of my kids
so what is that
i was working because he wasn't
uh he had a his appendix burst
and he like
he was off work for like a month you
know to recuperate they gave him pain
pills
and uh
he kind of got strung out on the pain
pills and that but because he was off
work
you know somebody had to work
so i started working um
it was a coolest job too um it was with
this company called rocket man i was a
walking vendor
basically i was the beer girl at ball
games and concerts
but i got to i've had to go to a lot of
really awesome concerts
that i traveled a lot um
ten days two weeks on the road doing
different events home for two or three
days if i was lucky
and then back on the road
and
you know he was home with the kids you
know
i was in colorado
working um
you know the band fish
um they were doing this like week-long
festival in colorado
and i signed up to work it because i had
i had close to 10 grand in the bank
that nobody knew i had squandered away
because i worked on tips and commissions
and
nobody knew i'd squandered this money
away and you know it's colorado you know
and it's a hippie band
and i haven't really
partied like that since before i had my
kids
so
i spent a week in colorado eating acid
and smoking weed and
you know just
having an amazing
time
and it was the mountains so my phone
didn't work
i had
i had an obama phone when they first
came out so like my my service was so
shitty like if
if there was a tree in your yard you
couldn't get signal
so i didn't think much of it when i
couldn't get a hold of my and my husband
and uh
when i got home
he was gone kids were gone
i'm like okay you know he's obviously
took the kids out to do something well
he didn't come home kids didn't come
home
i started to flip
um
by the second day home
i went to the police department one of
my kids
you know who cares about the man who's
like where are my kids
um
and they told me to turn around and put
my hands behind my back and
they arrested me
for trying to find out where my kids
were
i found i found out
you know after talking to a detective
a few hours after i got arrested
that while i was gone
my second husband called cps on himself
come get these little bastards or i'm
going to kill him they're [ __ ] up my
high and he hung up the phone
they traced a call
and
arrested him on
five counts child abuse child neglect
endangering the lives of dependents
there's like six different charges five
cases of each
they tried to charge me with the same
indiana is uh
it's called an all-at-fault state
uh basically like
because we were married
you know i had to know what he was doing
even though i wasn't there and when i
was home everything was fine
you know
i had to know
when i when i come home you know i'd ask
the kids like you know how you know did
you have fun do you have fun with daddy
and they'd say stuff like well daddy
whipped me
oh i asked well what were you doing when
daddy whipped you well we were fighting
or i
you know i did this i did that something
a kid would get popped on the butt for
you know
um
there were no bruises no marks that were
you know un
unlike something they would have
normally had you know being rowdy kids
so i didn't question anything you know i
just thought okay he popped him on the
butt so i i told the kids like well i
bet you won't do that again
well yeah
no
i didn't know at the time that like he
was being really brutal with them um
the they charged they tried to charge me
with the same and i
i took it to trial
and i won i want my case
um they found me innocent of all charges
uh my ex-husband however
signed the first plea agreement they
offered him
so
but even
even though i won my case
and i did everything right you know i i
jumped through all the cps hoops
when it came down to it they told me
that
no single woman
can work a full-time job take care of a
house pay the bills
and still be able to
get five kids ready for school and do
all the things that needs to be done
with five kids without
help so
i don't think they ever intended to get
my kids back
[Music]
when it came
when it came time for me to leave
indiana the re part of the reason i left
was
it wasn't because i didn't want to say
goodbye to my kids you know every
few days
i didn't want to keep making them say
goodbye to me
it broke their hearts
last time i saw them
last time i saw any of my kids with my
youngest son's fourth birthday
he just from ten a few days ago
i got him a bike
i taught him how to ride a bike
the last time i saw my kids
thank you
my old i'll still be in
16 in a few days
and my middle my middle boy
will be 13
a few days after that
when i was 13 year old that's
that was my boy
it was my baby my mini me
you came to l.a for what reason
to write a book and to kill myself
yeah the book just uh isn't quite done
yet
so
yeah
i from
as as long as i remember i always said
when i grew up i was gonna move to l.a i
was gonna move to california where it
was sunny and warm all year
um
where do you live now
i live in koreatown
are you homeless i'm residentially
challenged
okay
yeah it sounds a little better than
staying homeless yes
and you're still
using drugs
yeah
yeah i
i do fentanyl
a lot of fentanyl
do you smoke it or inject it or both
yeah um
i've overdosed
something like 22 times
the first time
they said that i was
i was
like full and dead for 13 minutes and 37
seconds
that was the paramedics
like time 13 minutes 13 minutes 37
seconds
and they called time of death
at 10 02 a.m
on my birthday my 37th birthday
and uh
my
fiance
uh i guess i could call him
um
they they told him
to you know
to
say goodbye to me and when they told him
that he uh
he flipped out and he like
he started beating on my chest and like
the paramedics the police officers that
showed up you know they were all trying
to pull him away i guess this is from
what i've been told
and he he just like wouldn't give up
um
he like
uh he he always kind of jokes and says
that he sold his soul
to like bring me back i don't believe
that kind of [ __ ] but you know
it's like
he says that he wasn't done with me yet
how do you how do you support yourself
now
um
i i boost
my fiance and i we boost
you've been caught
no
he has like a lot uh
so boosting which is stealing yeah
how do you go about doing this i've
heard different techniques
um some guys load up their backpack and
run out the back door other ones or it
just depends on
depends on the situation depends on the
store depends on how dope sick i am
if i get to a certain level of dopesick
i'll you know i'll
load my bag right in front of like every
employee in the store and dare somebody
to take it from me
i generally try to be more discreet than
that
if i can
i take like
the reusable shopping bags
and i'll put stuff in it like i'm
shopping and
go into a bathroom or something and load
up or um
or
um like i i cut
the lining in my purse
you know or in my jacket it just depends
on how big the stuff i'm getting is
but what how does how does boosting make
you feel what emotions does it bring up
and i don't even really think about it
you just do it you need to do it yeah
it's um it's what pays for my for my
dope it's what feeds me you're stealing
from a corporation so it seems okay
pretty much um like i stay away from
like the little mom and pop stores
um you know those people are
working paycheck to paycheck you know
they're like
they're just you know one bad month of
being out here away from being out here
also
um but like you know big stories like
target or or ralph's or
you know bed bath and beyond or you know
[ __ ] like that they have lost insurance
you know it's already figured into the
prices that we pay
you know we're already paying for it so
[ __ ] it
if there was something you could have
changed about your life
that may have put you in a different
position today what do you think that
might have been
um
i would have never taken a job where i
traveled i would have never gone away
from my kids for longer than a few hours
having different parents might have
helped too
if if i would have had different parents
initially then i wouldn't have gotten to
have my dad that adopted me
it was a really short period of time
that he was the most amazing man in the
world
um he did everything for me
so
he was it was really cool
he
he was like
the first person that ever really loved
me
so
i guess i've been spending you know the
bulk of my life trying to find somebody
to to love me like that
again
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um this important lesson uh
wow um
[Music]
don't dwell on the past
when you dwell in the past
then you can't move forward into the
future
it's horrifying to me how many of the
stories
interviewees that i talk to
share about sexual abuse in their
childhoods
and yours is one of the worst
this was your your real dad
my real dad and his friends
they
they were [ __ ] me and my sister they
were making us do [ __ ] to each other
and like they filmed a lot of it
like
it was
it was weird um
like there were these vhs tapes um
one of them was uh
full metal jacket they taped over full
metal jacket
of me and my sister and
this guy
we called him uncle buck
uh
i don't know
um you know uncle bucky uncle bucky is
what it was
i don't know it was some guy that that
my dad worked with my real dad worked
with
do you think a woman ever recovers from
that kind of experience as a young girl
not fully
i'm
i have yet to have a normal relationship
with a male
and i'll be 40 years old in uh in
december
i've and i still haven't had a normal
relationship
um
you could never fully trust a guy
and once
you know you're hurt
that to that degree
you know i get probably at such a young
age you know
you you never outgrow it you never get
over it
you're always waiting to get
[ __ ] off again
personally
it doesn't matter who the guy is
i'm always jumpy
when somebody when a guy touches me
if i don't initiate
then like
it freaks me
out you know how it's been
over 30 years and i still have
nightmares
which uh
i kind of feel sorry for my dude having
to deal with it like
it's it's like we he barely gets to
touch me and i know
i know it bothers him i know he
you know he obviously wants more than
you know
more [ __ ] than he gets
but
i just can't
i'm surprised i have five kids honestly
like
there uh
there were three instances
that my sister and i both got subpoenaed
to go to court
they found in somebody's like video
library on their computer
they found videos of us
and they like by
i don't know how they did it through um
there's some kind of software
where you know they can take like the
the pictures of the little girls in the
videos or you know the kids in the
videos and they run it against
i don't i assume dmv or something
pictures
but they can figure out you know who the
adult is
and my sister and i got subpoenaed on
three different occasions to go to court
and testify against
guys i had no clue who the [ __ ] they
were
you know um they had these videos on
their computers
because it was close to close to indiana
and
when you don't go to court
you get put in jail yourself
so as
even though you're the victim yeah
they don't care they want you to relive
it they don't care
they said that by
us you know having to relive it we were
keeping some other little kid from
having to go through it it's like okay i
don't care um i don't want you know i do
care
but that really that kind of sent me
back like a long time a lot of years
that
you know
it took me
hell i was in my early 30s before i was
finally able to talk about it openly
and i swear to god if anybody ever
touches one of my kids like i was
touched
i'll kill them i don't care i will kill
them
i won't ask questions i will just end
their [ __ ] lives
all right michelle thank you so much for
sharing your story
with the best of luck out there
with your fiancee
you